every day we have new issues new
problems new challenges I am the first
amongst the equals as far as the
mentoring process is concerned I have
learned that courage is the most
important attribute of a great leader
never ever underestimate your
competitors half the people in the
country are waiting for a telephone the
other half are waiting for a dial tone I
think at the end of the day most of our
energy comes from mental energy people
see us walking the talk lock you need
but be prepared to seize that lock let
the good news take the stairs and let
the bad news take the elevator while we
take over work very seriously we don't
take ourselves very seriously he's an
Indian IT industrialist he's the
co-founder of Infosys a multinational
corporation in providing business
consulting engineering and outsourcing
services as of September 2015 he was
listed by Forbes magazine as having a
net worth of 1.8 billion dollars he's nr
Narayan I'm Morty and here are his top
10 rules for success every day we have
new issues new problems new challenges
there is no doubt at all in fact I would
always say that today it's the it's the
nimble ones that eat the big ones right
it's not resized has value but not as
much value as it used to have 50 years
ago or 30 years ago so in that sense
certainly those corporations which use
speed imagination and excellence in
execution all the ones that will survive
and succeed so it is absolutely
necessary for us to come out with new
ideas new paradigms it is necessary for
us to keep our employees happy our
customers happy
our investors happy so I don't think the
the right is easy men on a scale of one
to ten how would you say you're faring
I would probably say six so that leaves
some pretty significant we had room of
course of course
but remember that we inversions are not
used to giving high marks so the primary
objective of every leader is to ensure
that there is successive generation of
leaders and one of the instruments for
doing that is mentoring mentoring is a
private relationship it's a voluntary
relationship the mentee chooses the
mentor at emphases so it's an honest one
it's one where the the amount the moral
dilemma the value system etc etcetera
can be discussed openly and honestly and
hopefully the mentor will use his or her
experience so do you have mentoring
throughout the company ormally
established and you are chief your chief
people officer I am the first amongst
the equals as far as the mentoring
process is concerned I have learned that
courage is the most important attribute
of a great leader courage to dream big
courage of conviction courage to take
board decisions courage to go against
conventional wisdom and courage to
travel the road less traveled we have
learnt a lot from every one of our
competitors there is no doubt at all and
we respect them one of the articles of
faith that emphasis is never ever
underestimate your competitors always
respect them learn what you can from
them and that's the way you can beat
them there was a huge opportunity for
software to be developed for
corporations because Hardware had become
cheaper and we realized that in India
there were lots of engineers who did not
have job opportunities therefore we said
why don't we build a company that
focuses on developing bespoke software
applications
for customers in developed nations he
started the company and you had a hard
time because India was not open to the
outside world was it those days the
government was very business unfriendly
it took us a year to get a telephone
connection we used to have a joke and
that is half the people in the country
are waiting for a telephone the other
half are waiting for a dial tone and
second it took us three years to get a
license to import a computer and that
was what you were about you needed the
computer absolutely job you were doing
absolutely so the the environment was
extremely business unfriendly but then
we said look there is a huge global
opportunity and therefore we should
stick with it we stuck with it and God
has been kind to us I think at the end
of the day most of our energy comes from
mental energy as long as you are in a
state of mind that is full of enthusiasm
hope confidence and joy then physical
energy will come you know frankly I
don't think we dreamed that we would
come this far I don't think we dreamed
that we would be ninety two thousand
people would probably have 10 or 12
million square feet the space I don't
think we dreamt will be four million
dollars plus in revenue a billion dollar
plus in profits around twenty billion
dollars in market cap operating in 39
countries none of that was trimmed I
think what was very clear in our mind
right from day one was that we would
seek respect respect from every one of
our stakeholders customers employees
investors vendor partners government of
the land and the society because our
logic was if we sought respect from
every one of these stakeholders we
revenues would automatically come
profits of comics attract cetera you
know that's the part to be honest that I
don't understand
and when you say that you thought
respect from all stakeholders and
everything else would follow how do you
actually hold that in your hand how do
you grasp at something tangible like
respect from stakeholders how do you
break it down into a process so that all
of emphasis can identify with it well it
is not that difficult in the sense that
you articulate your value system in a
very clear and concise manner for
example we use the acronym C life for
our value system that is C L IFE
customer focus leaders for example
integrity and transparency fairness and
excellence in execution so we have
created several case studies or to
demonstrate this value system we have
leaders talking about it and then people
see us walking the talk and there are
situations where you could take a
shortcut and we don't do that
and once you demonstrate the value
system by deed then you know the the
grapevine travels so fast I didn't okay
yeah I replicates itself you need a lot
because I have seen lots of smart people
lots of people who have worked hard they
haven't been blessed and you need lot
but at the same time let's remember
Louis Pasteur's words that God favors
the prepared mind so you have to be
prepared to take advantage of that lock
lock you need but be prepared to seize
that lock I have learned that the
leaders will have to be trustworthy
first before being high performers such
trustworthiness comes if we act
according to the adages let the good
news take the stairs and
at the bad-news take the elevator does
it bother you that expectations always
run so high of Narayan Murthi of
emphasis and you know with the
expectations always running so high and
so consistently high there's a risk of
people around you expecting too much and
hence that facing disappointment does
that bother you at all not really
because while we take over work very
seriously we don't take ourselves very
seriously all these things bought would
bother a person if he or she were to
take himself or herself very seriously
we don't do that so and how does a
corporation manage to not take itself so
seriously no the corporation takes it is
not the end of it not the individuals
within the corporation thank you so much
for watching
I made this view too because Jaya to
send asked me to so there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leaving the comments below and I'll
see what I can do I'd also love to know
which of the top 10 rules meant the most
to you hit you the hardest leave it in
the comments and I'll join in the
discussion thank you so much for
watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon